re Witherspoon billionaire now why
because Reese Witherspoon little sweet
suie sunshine in pink basically took a
book
club and said to authors I'll give you
part of my platform for you to talk
about your book because I'm lovely it's
free you're going to sell a bunch of
books tiny insignificant detail I'd like
the future rights to turn your book into
a movie and I'll pay you some sum or
I'll have a right of first refusal AK I
have I get the right to buy it before
anybody else and I'll pay you then for
it the author goes amazing Reese of
course perfect they come on Reese
basically AB tests so tests out which
books do best and depending on which
books do best ree buys their movie
rights and makes movies that create you
know tens of millions or hundreds of
millions of dollars in Revenue but Reese
doesn't tell that story Reese tells the
suie sunshine story of her selling the
books I think the other story is more
interesting and more people could learn
from it